[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Here is something
you don't see every day.
A long, jagged crack
splitting the ocean in two.
Well, at least that's
what it looks like.
In truth, the ocean
isn't breaking in half,
and, OK, that's
not even the ocean.
Lake Baikal is the world's
largest freshwater lake,
and considered by many to
be the deepest, oldest,
and clearest lake in the world.
But it's also a wild place,
one that can be very dangerous.
ALEXEY TROFIMOV: --
from small to big chips.
NARRATOR: And that's
what Alexander captured
in this picture-- a
distinct crack cutting
through Lake Baikal's
frozen waters, made possible
by the region's harsh
conditions, strong winds,
heavy snow, and
ever-shifting ice,
and that brutal environment
is exactly why he hired a team
to help him navigate
those dangers.
To Alexander and many like
him, the journey and the risk
is half the fun.
There is something
more satisfying
about skipping the easy
or safe place to travel.
To go past the
crowds and tourists,
to go a little bit further.
If you liked this episode,
be sure to check out
this one on another peculiar
place-- a prison island
off the coast of Florida.
MAN: Access to the island
can only done by sea plane
or by boat.
Our plane was not equipped
for landing on the water,
so I enjoyed an afternoon of
picture-taking from the air.
NARRATOR: And as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]